here with reaction two former press
secretaries
by the way that is a job that frankly
you couldn't pay me uh a hundred million
dollars a day to do
uh kailee mcadaney also co-host of
outnumbered and fox news contributor ari
fleischer
all right both of you had the hardest
job ever am i being too harsh in my
grading i'll let you correct me if you
think i'm wrong
well first off kaylee and i didn't get
paid that amount of money
either i'm very aware no
sean your your grades are right on
target you know if you remember there
was a former defense secretary robert
gates he worked for barack obama and
therefore for joe biden and he wrote in
his book that joe biden's been wrong
about every major foreign policy issue
of the last 30 years and i think
watching joe biden in these six months
you know that's true
but you can extend it now to domestic
policy he's misinterpreted his mandate
he doesn't have a mandate but he thinks
he's fdr
junior licensed to go on a massive
trillion dollar spending spree
and he's not that was not what the 2020
election was about
and he's out of sync with where the
american people are
you know kaley i actually said to a
mutual friend of ours dan scavino
after the election at some point i said
you might want to go out and patent
donald trump hashtag miss me yet
2024 because
i think six months in this is a
dramatically different country
yeah dan should have taken yeah dan
should have taken you up on that sean i
mean you're exactly right you know i was
with secretary pompeo earlier today
here at turning point and we were
talking about some issues you know
one by one you look at the covid lab
leak you know that we knew in the trump
administration that was the most obvious
source but
here you had biden shutting down the
investigation even though secretary
pompeo
and the trump administration warned him
you know giving a huge
just pass to china it did originate in
the lab at least every sign points
towards that
you move on over to immigration the
images on the border today sean
were galling the biggest group that fox
news had ever seen arriving on our
southern border
get this as biden considers rolling back
one another trump policy title 42 which
keeps families out because of covid
health concerns so he rolls that back
you're going to see even more and more
and more on our border and those are
just two issues of many your grades
were spot on instead of three f's i had
an f minus on my sheet but hey i'll take
the three f's
just as much as the f minus i thought
three f's for one topic was pretty
big all right so the media though ari
fleischer they're complicit here
i called it the candidate protection
program now it's the presidential
protection program
they don't show joe's cognitive
struggles they're not talking about we
lost energy independence they're not
showing the
the kids in cages in the middle of a
pandemic sleeping on top of each other
down at the border
they're not reporting what china and
russia and iran are doing
they they give joe a pass on everything
the same people that you know if
if donald trump said one bad thing in a
tweet lost their minds
so what the american people need to
realize is the media bias which used to
be a liberal bias and
it still is a liberal bias but they have
now gotten in such a habit they did it
to donald trump and his staff
now they're going to do it to all
republicans they
overtly take sides sometimes they do it
directly and sometimes i do it by
omission but the fact that they haven't
played a lot of those clips some of
those clips sean
just stop you in your in your feet and
just say what is going on is he
okay people do need to see that and you
know if that was george bush if that was
john mccain if that was mitt romney let
alone donald trump
the media would be pounding them for it
they'd be showing it all the time
they protect they take sides they
protect and it's not the republican side
they protect
can you imagine kaylee if this was
donald trump's record
or donald trump was struggling
cognitively like this what would it be
like
i can't imagine i i mean look i i was at
the podium when
i was asked over and over again about
his trips to walter reed and they were
routine
visits that he took but they were
convinced something sinister something
must have been wrong with the president
he must have been covering something up
they don't ask those questions in the
briefing room nor do they ask
really important questions like hey why
did it take four days to denounce
communism you have peter ducey saying
you know will you denounce communism
where's the roaring
loud press corps behind peter ducey
demanding an
answer on that on censorship partnering
with facebook
to censor everyday americans we keep
hearing about these 12 americans
who give misinformation well why does
the government have a list of these 12
americans
you don't have the press corps you don't
have the shouting questions because they
simply do not care
ari is right they take sides all right
kayleigh mcadamy arie fleischer thank
you both hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else